i just wanted to ask you if you're ready
to have the best performance of your
life yes
let's go let's go check it out come on
are we just waiting on the robot
yeah just waiting for the robot
[Applause]
all right i'll get you started right
here we're cutting things close right
now but this is what happens on tour
things are constantly changing different
stuff is thrown at you all the time and
that's what these girls are gonna have
to get used to if they want to be pop
stars all i can do is hope that what we
did in the studio works and everybody
remembers what to do start out here and
then remember when it's that weird
technology music come back here
and then at the end of the song walk in
a straight line across who's playing the
robot there's it's a robot
there's nobody inside the robot no
it's legit the coolest thing ever oh my
god that's what the entire world is
going to think
so we're going to stick to that story
ready here we go all right kids kill it
i'm going get settled get settled i
should be full out all right
[Music]
you